good morning jack in my last video I
said that the order of the alphabet is
older than any word in our language and
that's kind of true no word is
pronounced or spelled the way that it
was back then but there are some words
that stretch back a really long time
like before written language before
agriculture Eve and you can tell because
they show up in real languages that
haven't been related for a really long
time one of those hyper conserved words
that appears in Norse and Slavic and
Sanskrit and Greek is the word fart fart
is one of the oldest words in the
English language and that is just one of
the 14 facts that I'm gonna tell you
about first today why because I'm the
master of my own destiny and I get to do
what I want Benjamin Franklin wrote a
letter to the Royal Society called firt
proudly in the letter he calls on them
to create a kind of XPrize to give a
reward to a scientist who can make fart
smell not just non smelly but good more
than 99% of the gas of your farts is
actually odorless
Art's are mainly composed of carbon
dioxide hydrogen sometimes nitrogen and
oxygen and methane
yes only sometimes methane about half of
people don't have methane in their farts
sir or not you do depends on the kind of
organisms that live in your intestines
it's weird methane has no smell methane
is also called natural gas and we use it
a lot in our houses now before it's sent
to our houses an odour is added to it if
there's a leak you want to be able to
smell it before it explodes and
everything died the chemical most
commonly used for this is tert-butyl
file which is a sulfur containing
compound sulfur compounds are
notoriously stinky and yes sulfur
compounds are the things that make farts
stinky so that 1% contains stuff like
hydrogen sulfide which is terribly
smelly because it's very toxic and we
want to know if it's round there are now
actually medicines that you can take
that bind to sulfur compounds so your
Vaart don't smell too bad
now people don't always fart methane but
cows they do right though I mean maybe a
little bit but cows do contribute a mass
of methane to the atmosphere where it is
a potent greenhouse gas which is a
problem but the vast majority of that
gas is not released from the back end
but from the front in burps it wasn't
until 1974 s Blazing Saddles that the
first audible fart was heard in a movie
theater well in a movie probably there
were people people have farted in movie
theatres the first river joke though in
James Joyce Shakespeare Dante
Chaucer Arabian Nights all contained
fart jokes the earliest joke in history
that we have a record of he's a fart
joke I'm taking some liberties here as a
translator but basically here's the
chill only one thing of all things has
not yet happened a young lady never
farted in her new husband's lap in the
4000 years since that joke was written
uh it's how I guess is that happen some
people are able to actually take air
into their rectum intentionally and that
is the trick behind lahpet Amane who was
a 19th century performer who was able to
play the melodies of popular songs with
his but he performed for princes and
kings and for Sigmund Freud but he was
not the first flatulence Augustine
recorded being entertained by one such
person in the fifth century oh excuse me
a moment I must prepare call that
blowing a raspberry why guns and British
rhyming slang farts were raspberry tarts
the average person farts over 10 times
per day about a liter of total gas in
volume since around 25% of that gas is
hydrogen it would take two million
people's farts over a full year to fill
up the Hindenburg with hydrogen I did
the math myself John I'll see you on
Tuesday